auf dem mars passiert etwas ziemlich
mysteriös nicht nur dass dort methan
gefunden wurde ein gas das hier auf der
erde vor allem durch tiere und pflanzen
produziert wird das absolut seltsame
dabei es gibt jahreszeitliche
schwankungen und bisher konnte das
phänomen geologisch einfach nicht
geklärt werden gibt es also leben auf
dem mars für und wider jetzt bei klicks
und science fiction herzlich willkommen
ja es kann sich wirklich niemand
erklären als die ersten vorkommen von
methan auf dem mars gemessen wurden
da waren noch alle überzeugt dass es
eine geologische erklärung geben müsse
aber hier stoßen die wissenschaftler
innen immer öfter an grenzen
zitat das ungewöhnlichste an dieser
beobachtung sind die relativ großen
schwankungen
wir versuchen immer noch zu verstehen
wie es zu diesen saisonalen schwankungen
kommen dran so chris webber vom jet
propulsion laboratory jpl der nasa
gegenüber dem wissenschaftsmagazin
science bisher konnte noch keine
stichhaltige erklärung aus der geologie
gefunden werden im gegenteil immer mehr
deutet auf eine biologische erklärung
hin mit den bisherigen modellen konnten
die großen schwankungen einfach nicht
erklärt werden der methangehalt ist zwar
wahnsinnig gering steigt aber
jahreszeitbedingt um mehr als das
doppelte von dem schnitt 0,3 auf bis zu
0,7 parts per million also 0,3 bis 0,7
millionen und das immer im spätsommer in
der nähe des äquators eine biologische
erklärung wäre wobei noch reine
spekulation zitat vielleicht wird das
methan welchen quellen es auch immer
entstand von irgendetwas absorbiert
vielleicht von poren im oberflächen
gestein so meteore wurden vermutet aber
auch diese idee musste verworfen werden
setzt massenhafte einschläge ließen den
methangehalt überhaupt nicht ansteigen
nummer vom goddard space flight center
der nasa
zitat die andere erklärung über die kaum
jemand spricht an die aber fast jeder
denkt ist biologische aktivität auch vom
leben erwarten wir schließlich eine
gewisse jahreszeitliche abhängigkeit
also was ist da im boden was das gas
produziert das hier auf der erde zum
beispiel kühe beim rüsten ausstoßen oder
bakterien die verfallen es ist wirklich
ziemlich rätselhaft im april 2018 soll
der trays gas orbiter kurz tgo der
europäischen raumfahrtagentur esa mit
der erkundung der metallvorkommen
beginnen dann erreicht er den geplanten
orbit um den mars um mit der
untersuchung zu starten es ist eines der
haupt missionsziele des orbiters
spurengase also trace gas also die
geringen methan
in der marsatmosphäre zu analysieren und
die quellen zu finden
vielleicht wissen wir also schon bald
mehr wenn er kein video dazu verpassen
wollte und auch zu allen anderen themen
durch mal hier ein aber aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
denn ansonsten kriegt ihr nicht mit wenn
ein neues video online geht hier geht es
weiter mit dafür draufklicken
sensationsfund auf dem mars theaters ist
auch ziemlich spannend ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran